the longest film to win a Foreign
Language Academy Award had a running
time of over seven hours while the
longest film to win a Best Picture had a
running time of almost four hours yet
the film's in this category range
between six and 35 minutes long
here are the nominees for best animated
short film slides Aishah
Theodore a chef borrowed time Andrew
coats and Lou Kamala's pear cider and
cigarettes
Robert Valley and Cara speller pearl
Patrick Osbourne Piper Allen barrel
arrow and Mark sondheimer and the Oscar
goes to
Piper Allen very yellow and my son
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Allan Valera and Mark sondheimer
[Music]
Wow honestly we're only here because of
the kind support and mentorship of many
I have to thank John Lasseter Andrew
Stanton Lindsay Colin Jim Morris and Ed
Catmull my family my parents my wife
Nancy my three little Piper's at home
who inspired this story he Hoke Cora
marchello I love you and I may you
always have the courage to face your
fears we share this award with everyone
who worked on Piper thank you so much
especially in light of the great work of
our fellow nominees we are so deeply
honored to take this award tonight
accept this award tonight to my family
and friends I love you
to all of you who enjoy Piper out there
and wish to swell throughout thank you
so much
[Applause]